hello the internet i'm gav i'm dan we're
the slow-mo guys and back in the day
daniel before we had our channel one of
my favorite shows on youtube was is it a
good idea to microwave this it almost
never was a good idea really one of my
favorite videos they did was they put an
airbag in a microwave
yeah and as you can imagine
ain't no microwave no more
after that thing with that video though
you couldn't really see exactly what
happened because they just sort of put
it in ran out the door and it exploded
so we have no idea what happened so
let's reveal what actually happened by
using state of the art slow motion cap
we all know what's gonna happen yeah the
airbag's gonna blow the door off it's
gonna blow the bloody door right off
gonna blow the bloody door right off in
it yeah great let's go loving the old
retro knob microwave thanks yeah these
are actually quite hard to get hold of
there's a reason we've got this though
and that's because all you have to do
with one of these ones is put what
you're putting in into the microwave and
close it
if you set the dial to on and plug it in
it will automatically just turn on and
go so you can be miles away just plug it
in and it's gone with one of the digital
ones that's not the same you have to be
there and pushing buttons i don't want
to be anywhere near this thing the only
airbags we could get hold of had these
pins in
which is no good for us
because we need these cables to be
attached to them so i've got these jump
cables
which will hopefully make it work
because without that
it doesn't do anything it just cooks yes
it gets a bit melts a little bit
so you need the cables in there to get
it to work little antenna all right i'm
gonna film this on the phantom flex 4k
i've actually set it to hd
giving us a maximum frame rate of 2000
frames a second and a very long trigger
cable so i can trigger the camera from
safety over there safety with daniel oh
no
you ready yeah
[Music]
oh
god
that took off the door went flying
goodness me
whoa
bloody hell
have you unplugged it yeah it's
unplugged
that's got some distance on it look at
that it must have hit the fence as well
it did hit the fence
careful beyond still hot yeah
oh that
airbag pong
uh familiar smell on the slower guys
oh properly bowed it
look at that
bloody came
clean off oh
you know i'm surprised none of it went
over the fence it went upwards yeah
it came out with some force that is
wicked
the microwave's not light and it's just
lifted it off the table can you imagine
doing that in a kitchen
you would never highlight the kit yeah
i like it billowing smoke as it goes
down
definitely adds to the effect
because it ejected the door so far sort
of want to get a wide
of it
okay maybe just focusing on the door if
it happens that way again
can we make it fancy and maybe put some
powder paint in there and colors and
stuff we're really into powder paint
these days that's what our channel's
become it's like can we put powder paint
on that yeah well it's like it makes it
look nice you know let's do it let's
burn some powder paint
all right we've got a black microwave
now
i'm gonna color it up though some
primary colors
chuck a bunch of green on first of all
not a primary color but all right well
all right yeah good point what i meant
was like uh
yeah i've just screwed myself over there
obviously it's not a primary color
made with blue and yellow
so
i don't know why i said that
but talking to blue
well the chance of this will just come
out as like brown or something oh it's
definitely going to yeah all right
that'll do that that'll do
okay then i'm setting the timer on the
microwave
is it nerve-wracking doing that in front
of the door yeah
even though i know it's not plugged in
it's impossible
let's hope this bag is
a gooden
okay we ready yeah
surprises me every time
gets me every time
oh
my god
a week
what's week i i want to see it so it
looks like
it's done identical it's like identical
patterns it's completely symmetrical
except not quite as far
i wonder if it's the powder paint that
had that effect
now uh i've seen the footage and you
haven't yeah
not quite as far would be incorrect
really yeah
how's that well look it's not gone as
far as the other one unless you're
telling me it bounced off the fence
and then came back it annihilated the
feds
oh so if anything it was even stronger
because it bounced further back off the
fence
do you want to see the footage yeah i
mean how much do you think you'd have to
pay me to stand here yeah you would
break a bone oh you would absolutely get
everything in the face it could do some
serious damage all right here we go
chillin
it's like a jet trail isn't it the paint
leaves yeah like a powdered trail whoa
yeah that was going some speed
i play it ding the fence it like
properly bounced the fence panel oh whoa
there's like a gap in the fence after
that that's some seriousness might have
broken the fence
look at it
if you're stood there you'd be dead
is that a car crash sounds like it yeah
it was
cool well this one jumped back about two
meters there it's almost like the
explosion caused the microwave to go
that way and the doors to go that way in
equal amounts of force yeah it just
turned into brown muck
in there
there's a lot of paint in there but it's
completely mixed and just yeah it looks
like the green on the front was all that
came out yeah look cool though yeah i
like the little trail that left behind
well it looks like we found a pretty
consistent way to weaponize a microwave
door you couldn't get me to stand in
front of that there's no way you
definitely wouldn't want to do that no
don't try that one yourselves that's a
real dangerous one yeah obviously we did
it because we saw it in a video
professionals and everything though
we're all professionals yeah
professionals yeah hopefully you enjoyed
that video feel free to follow us on
twitter go and watch the old microwave
show it was top and we've got a second
channel which you should subscribe to if
you would like for a bit bts and
obviously bunga subscribe on this one
don't smash the like button though it's
extremely delicate it's fragile very
gentle with the like button a lot of
youtubers telling everyone to smash the
like button just caress it gently
vandalism yeah
done let's go